now for years prince harry worked with
mental health charities alongside the
duke and duchess
of cambridge to try and help people feel
able to talk about their struggles
last night it was revealed the duchess
of sussex struggled with her mental
health
during her time at kensington palace
with megan claiming she suffered
suicidal thoughts
and despite all the work done by the
younger royals in that area
she says she was told by the palace that
she couldn't be helped
let's talk more about this with james
mcveigh the mental health ambassador
and a member of the group the vamps
james hello to you
when you heard those claims by megan in
the interview
last night that she was at her
lowest point and there was no help
despite her reaching out
what was your reaction to it i just
thought that it was
desperately sad um and i think we we
always need to remember that regardless
of one's background
mental health struggles should be taken
extremely seriously
yeah it's it's interesting isn't it that
megan said that she reached out
and was told well you can't get help
because we know prince harry has spoken
openly about his own struggles and his
own
search for help that his own brother had
urged him to to seek help to get
counselling to deal
with uh the difficulties that he was
enduring and yet megan found no such
support
absolutely and i think you know for for
decades there's been
an immense pressure um on members of the
royal family
to maintain stiff upper lips and and i
don't really feel that they've adopted
um sort of the
necessary nuances around mental health
and the discussion around mental health
until recently and yes the uh there was
a charity set up
by prince william um which does
incredible work but i think that that's
great but that's only gonna
really sort of cut through when the
whole of the royal family
institution um adopts that that mantra
as well
so i i would hope that the royal family
would lead lead by example and it
doesn't seem to be
um happening at the moment does it well
i suppose there's the distinction there
you talk about the royal family in the
institution
and it seems from what megan is saying
that she sought help from the
institution
rather than from the family themselves
but we don't know of course we're
hearing
one side we haven't yet heard from
buckingham palace
about their version of what went on
but i wonder in in speaking about this
in vocalizing how difficult things got
for her
what impact does that have somebody in
in megan's position to speak in these
work
terms i think it's just been you know
an extremely difficult few years for
them
and it struck me that she's she was at
breaking point with that and
you know the fact that they they moved
out of the country i mean
i don't blame them but what i would say
is i think it is inspirational to see
you know a woman um with her success
um to to be so vocal about mental health
um and i i just say again that we need
to recognize that everyone should be
listened to and taken seriously
um when they're discussing mental health
struggles and there's been things in the
media
on social media that have sort of been
um suggesting that maybe
there's been lying around that and i
just think that's disgusting we have to
recognize the severity
of when people communicate their their
mental health struggles because look at
the the consequences any sort of
high profile case where someone's
you know sort of like been having these
mental health struggles they never end
well
um and you know you think think of
caroline flack that was trending on
twitter
that that's just the prime example and
we can't we have to do all we can to
reduce
things tragedies like that uh occurring
again
uh you are also an anti-bullying
campaigner james and i wonder what
you think the palace needs to do now
with the the claims
of bullying that have been made by some
former palace
aides yeah i mean as
as is important with mental health
discussions i think allegations around
bullying are equally is
important and should be taken seriously
i do
think um it's it's slightly interesting
when you're comparing
other controversies in the royal family
uh that perhaps
once looked into by the royal family and
that
i think that's disappointing that
perhaps there's been more
um focus on on this when they maybe
should have done it as well but that
doesn't underpin
as i said that there are potentially
victims of bullying that should be
looked into too
i just think that the royal family and
the institution needs to
you know move forward with with these
discussions and start evolving with the
times because uh it seems that a lot of
people are kind of getting sick of them
being
slightly draconian with some of these
protocols
yeah i suppose many of us would have
thought that that is what they've been
doing with the heads together campaign
the younger royals
certainly are you talking about the
wider family
yeah abs absolutely and and as i said
before it
it's not going to work you know these
charities are brilliant but they will
only work if the whole family and the
wider institution
does adopt that that mantra as well um
it's great doing those little things but
you know the the evidence is here today
isn't it that
that there's clearly still uh some
people that are
struggling to get up to up to the times
with it
james vay thank you thank you